おはようございます。
アイプリニュースのお時間です。
今日は2026年6月10日、最新のおねがいアイプリ、ひみつのアイプリ、そしてアイプリバースの情報をお届けします。
まずはアニメおねがいアイプリから。
毎週日曜の朝9時30分から放送中のこの作品は、各配信サイトでも最新話が更新されています。
視聴の際は公式サイトで配信状況を確認してください。
かわいいキャラクターたちの活躍がますます盛り上がっていますね。
続いて、ゲームひみつのアイプリからの話題です。
6月4日から新たにおりびあというアイプリが登場しました。
おりびあはバズリウムコーデをまとい、ぐみとのデュオコーデも注目されています。
さらに、サンリオキャラクターズとのコラボカードも4種類登場し、コラボソングなかよしパーティーも楽しめます。
ゲーム内でぜひチェックしてみてください。
そして、アイプリバースの最新情報です。
6月11日からおねがいアイプリ2だんがスタート予定です。
こちらでも新アイプリおりびあが登場し、バズリウムコーデやあおい、ぐみのデュオコーデに注目が集まっています。
また、2026年夏にはおねがいアイプリ公式ファンブックが発売予定で、読者モデルとしてアイプリが誌面に登場するキャンペーンも実施中です。
ファンのかたはぜひ応募してみてください。
グッズ情報も見逃せません。
プリズムストーン東京駅店ではおねがいアイプリの新しいランチグッズが入荷しています。
スライドトリオセットはおはし、スプーン、フォークの3点セットで、いのりさん、あおいさん、フォーチュさんのかわいいデザインです。
プラコップも同時に販売中。
お店で手に取ってみてはいかがでしょうか。
さらに、アイプリバースのおねがい1だんフルコーデガチャは6月10日までの稼動です。
スペースダイナーオレンジ、チェックメイトブルー、ハッピーデニムイエローなど、300円で1枚にフルコーデがプリントされたカードが手に入ります。
かわいいコーデがそろっているので、まだのかたはお早めにどうぞ。
最後に、アーケードゲームおねがいアイプリ2だんも好評稼動中です。
ぐみ、おりびあ、いのり、あおいのキャンディポップシリーズのカードが登場し、ファンのかたに人気です。
詳細は公式サイトでチェックしてください。
今日は大きな新情報は少なめですが、アニメの最新話配信、ゲームの新キャラ登場、グッズの新商品など、アイプリの世界はますます楽しく広がっています。
これからも最新情報をお伝えしていきますのでお楽しみに。
以上、今日のアイプリニュースでした。